[music]
K
I was born in the city of Kiev in the former
Soviet Union and where I graduated from a high
school specialized in the German
language. I spoke German fluently
when I graduated from school and And after
that I entered the
Noso Moscow State University in the
city of Moscow as a faculty  Mathematics and
cybernetics graduated in 1989
and entered graduate school at Moscow State University. But
unfortunately, my family had to leave,
we moved to Israel where I continued my
graduate studies, that is, I entered
again and defended my dissertation at
Tel Aviv University in applied
mathematics, after which I moved to
Berkeley University of California at Berkeley
where I was a post com for 3 years and then
got a position at
North Carolina State University where I have been working since
2002 where I have spent my entire career in
mathematics I started as an assistant professor and
then
[music]
professor I work on
conservation laws let me  I’ll try
to give an example that can be
understood by
anyone, what are conservation laws,
imagine a
road segment in Boston and you can
think about the density of cars on this
road segment
and the change in the number of cars, the
number of cars on this segment
depends on how many cars enter
into this segment And how many enter
this segment You can make a simple
mathematical equation that says
that the rate of change of cars on a
certain segment of the street in the city of
Boston depends on how many
cars enter minus how many cars
leave this is a law this is a conservation law
and mathematical equations the rate of
change of cars density  cars on a
segment is a derivative and we
equate, we use the
well-known Ostrogradsky formula and
we get the conservation law
that the number of cars on a certain
segment of the street is equal to the flow of cars
through this
segment. So you can replace e
cars, for example, with the density of gas in a
pipe and Density of gas in a pipe  the
rate of change of gas in a pipe is calculated
is changed by the flow of gas through this
pipe this is a conservation law you
can also think about chemical elements You
can think about the number of bacteria
And you can think about any density of
any substance and write a similar
model and it may be a little more complicated
maybe a little  easier with different
parameters and
in the end you get a
mathematical equation that needs to be
solved and it is impossible to solve it using analytical
methods, so
we develop special methods
called numerical methods that
we try to solve these equations and give an
approximate solution to the
analytical one, which is the answer to many
problems.  for many tasks and will explain
How various phenomena occur and at the
same time predict what will
happen to these phenomena in the
near
[music]
future Well,
now uh
Well, for example, one of the tasks we are
doing is the
movement of
bacteria, what is called kemo taxis,
this is happening  from two words Latin
taxis, that is, movement and Kema - This is from the
word Here are chemical processes, for
example, a bacterium reacts to
Well, it may not necessarily be a
chemical element, it could
be Air, it could be
light and then it will be called
phototaxis or if  a bacterium moves in
water it will be aquataxi if it is
some kind of chemical process it is
chemotaxis and the bacterium moves towards the
highest
Well, the highest concentration or light or
some chemical gradients or water
and movement the active movement of the bacterium is a
very important process in biology and
it is not completely  has been studied and a lot of
parameters need to be taken into account
when you do some experiments,
so there are models that describe the
collective movement of bacteria, for example
in water or in the air or somewhere else, and
this is also connected, for example,
with the
development of cancerous tumors, this helps
in these studies and here  our
mathematical models that we solve using
numerical
methods help biologists, in
particular, to understand the behavior of bacteria to
understand movement to understand how bacteria
concentrate where they move and we
can easily vary various
parameters in our models and the
behavior of bacteria depends on these parameters
then we can give some
information experiment to scientists who
are engaged in experiments so that they
can select the correct parameters in their experiments
and see what
happens
and this is a very interesting task and by the way
the experiments were carried out here in
mit Yes, for example, we are working on
shallow water issues or
tsunami issues, we can we count models
predicting the movement of a tsunami that
finds ashore. And
there are also waves that are called
killer waves; these are no longer shallow water, but deep
water. We also know how to predict
their behavior and they are very important for the
movement of, for example, ships. Because
these waves appear very unexpectedly in the
ocean and can be  not safe for the
movement of ships, so I also deal with
problems that for dynamics, for example,
there are models in which
there are very different parameters, large and small,
and for example, using one method. It is necessary to solve
problems where
large parameters exist and other methods.
It is necessary to solve problems where the
parameters are small. That’s very  It is important
now to create universal numerical
methods that will work for the entire
Spectrum of parameters and this is important for the
movement of aircraft, for example, there is the
so-called Mach number, it varies from
very small to very large and
depending on this, the
movement of air around the aircraft
is described by various models and so
I would like to create a numerical method that
would be universal for different models
with different parameters, that is, applied
mathematics It is the same
everywhere, if there is a conservation law that
is described by a system of partial differential
equations, then we
can create a numerical method that will
help this model decide to simulate
the results and predict what  there will be
[music]
next You sweat modern mathematics
covers Well, it’s like a much
wider range of questions that goes far
beyond the everyday ones So these are the
largest search engines
thanks to which we find
information they Well, if I may say so, they are
stuffed with mathematical
models So these are  allow us to
adjust the parameters for issuing the result of
our search query and, in other
words, for the same Google request.
It can give you some links and another
system can give you other links, that
is, there are mathematical models,
parameters again. So I talked about
biological applications, but in principle
from the point of view of mathematics  in general, this is of
great importance. This
biological application in physics in
chemistry or in search engines, if there is
a model, we can vary the parameters
and produce different results,
then mathematical models, for example, everyone
knows about investment funds. Yes, these are
mathematical models.
And
online stores are mathematical
models in  which are also Well, for example,
both Probability Theory
and Igor Theory are used, for example, now
such an
area as big data analysis is of great importance;
mathematics now has
applications in both social sciences and
political science. When we no longer only
consider models and try to
study and calculate them and  get some
results And we are also trying to
process the set of data that is
now collected thanks to technological
progress and
And in general, the processing of this data
also happens with the help of mathematical
models But after you
have processed this data, you probably want, we all
want to accept what  decisions
based on And this is also Mathematics, this is
optimal control, this is
game theory, that is, practically mathematics is everywhere,
these are such beautiful
examples. I believe that
data processing today is a
new vein in mathematics
that
can really
show, in general, the importance of
mathematics  for today
[music]
you understand, if you answer
this question very quickly, then of course you want to
immediately say there are proofs of the
firm theorem or hypothesis for Ankara, but
mathematics is very extensive and there are
fundamental
mathematical studies, there are
applied ones, there have been a lot of discoveries
Well, a lot of discoveries have happened And
in the XX XXI century and very small discoveries,
you understand what is happening in mathematics,
every mathematician who deals with
science at his own level creates
some small discovery and all together a
big
interesting process develops and in a
lot of In general, in the promotion of a big idea
and some big ones -  then the discoveries of
proofs are closer to me than those discoveries
that occurred in the field of applied
mathematics and numerical methods and maybe
they did not attract such general
public attention and And as a
proof. That’s how I said
Fermat’s theorem or the Pon caret conjectures, but they
made, in general, an invaluable contribution to
the development of applied mathematics,
this is connected with the
numerical development of numerical methods
after the Second World
War, all over the world mathematics was given to
the development of precisely numerical methods
in the fifty-four fifty-nine
years and here Professor Godunov in
Novosibirsk and here Peter Laks they
were working on similar problems in
namely the solution
and simulation of various models, and this
seems to me to have made a big breakthrough in
applied mathematics and which
now allows us to deal with more
advanced tasks including
data processing and big data and artificial
intelligence and so on. It seems to me
that this
part would be very unusual and very  in its own
way
[music] is
new, so I called it Of course, this is what In
my field, Godunov’s methods are, in
general, the main basic methods
used by mathematicians. Well,
again, this may very well be a narrow
part of mathematics. But if we talk
about the great Russian mathematicians
who  contributed not only to
numerical methods, but also to applied and
fundamental mathematics, this is, of course,
Kolmogorov’s theory of function, of course
Chebyshov’s
[music]
his Chebyshov’s polynomials,
which he made, are very
often used and in numerical methods,
of course, Ostrogradsky, who derived an
extremely popular physics formula
that is constantly used and  in physics
and in numerical methods and in other
fields and
from I will even
name Lebedev, the founder of
computer technology, from the Russians
Ladyzhinskaya worked on differential
equations Oleinik she worked on
partial differential equations
differential equations and
are those equations that
describe the models that we  we solve using
numerical methods, that is,
we made one of the biggest contributions to
the development of differential equations,
modeling and numerical
methods, also Barin
Blat from mathematicians may not be
Russian, Berkeley director Alexander
Chorin also made a very large contribution to the
development of numerical methods and
modeling
[music]
probably helped me  just
uh, love for mathematics is what I love
to do, this is what I want to do and I don’t
consider it work. It’s just a joy for me.
I just love mathematics and I
think about it all the time. I live by it. It’s
practically in the first place in my life.
how can this
be not very well, in general yes Mathematics
is like everything for me so it
helps me and I don’t think about
when and what I need to do in
mathematics because I think about it all the time
and of course the
support from everyone helped  sides of the family
because I may be forward to another
point that
I would not say that it hinders but does not
help, the infrastructure that has
been created can be in the scientific environment at
universities, which is tuned
mainly to the male
team. As you correctly noted, this is
mainly dominated by a
man dominates  in this profession,
therefore, here are Elementary questions
and some kind of maternity leave
or just a vacation or just some kind of
classes not related to mathematics,
right up to the point that in the evening or early
in the morning
you need to take care of some family
issues. This of course does not help And  it didn’t
help, and now it seems to me that the situation has
become much better than it was 203 years
ago when I started, there was simply absolutely
no help and no understanding
that a woman might have some things to do.
Family affairs, women’s affairs with
children, this doesn’t help. And  I
think
that and also, the scientific system itself is
set up in the academy. So you
need to move very often. First, you
study in graduate school, then it is considered that you
need to do a postdoc in
another place. It’s not good to do it where
you
received your dissertation, and then you
have to go to work back in  one place
to look because usually if the
faculties don’t really like to hire their
own students or graduate students,
then there is still a lot of moving and traveling
and having, for example, if a woman has a family
and children, this is not very
easy and not to mention the fact that
usually working in  scientific environment
If a woman wants to become a professor, she
must start looking for a job
somewhere a year before and it can be offered
anywhere, and then, of course, family members
must be
ready to follow the woman professor
around the world and this, of course, imposes
huge restrictions
on women’s ability to move around
for sure  men may have the same problems,
but it seems to me that this system was
set up there in the last
century
and it was believed that probably mostly
male and female professors do not work
and therefore such a system would be
acceptable now, here I am the head of the
department of mathematics at the
University of North Carolina  and
every year when we hire
new young professors, be it a
man or a
woman, almost
90% of young
scientists always have a spouse
or partner who is also involved in
science or works naturally, and
we always try to help them somehow with
their partners or in  industry or in
academia in universities, at our
university, for example,
special programs have appeared to help the partners of young
professors whom we hire,
this is a very unusual phenomenon and I am very
proud that our university
has such a program and
now when I came to work for 20
years  ago there were kindergartens,
no one knew what they were doing with children at
our faculty, but
now we have a very good developed
infrastructure, half of us have a
lot of women, young professors,
and so we are proud that we, in
general, find opportunities to help and
attract  them and create more
comfortable working conditions for them,
and especially I think it is very important in the
work of a professor to find a balance
between work and, well, private life,
family life, I see how hard
our young specialists work, I know
how much work needs to be invested in order to
achieve what  - the same in the academy And this is
not trivial, and I want
young scientists,
in addition to doing mathematics, which they
love and want to do all the time,
just like me, so that they still
have time for their personal life, for some
travel and just  the opportunity to sometimes
get distracted Unfortunately, this is not very
easy to do, and despite the fact that I really
love mathematics and despite the fact that I really
love my profession
and positions. This is how I work as a
professor of mathematics and in
the department, after all, academic life
requires constant tension and
constant
work, that’s just
[music]
constant Well, the tasks that
this
organization faces, in general, are
to create
a team that would help
girls and girls and women who
are interested in mathematics. That’s exactly it,
but to
advance along their Well, not only a
career ladder, probably, but to get a
decent education in this  area and
help them
also in finding
good connections in terms of not communication. How
can we understand this from the point of view of
everyday life there, but connections, namely
scientific connections, travel to conferences,
reports, work with various scientists,
guest reports by women scientists
who showed in particular to young
girls and women that  there is an opportunity
to do mathematics, if
they wish, if they like it
and that there are women mathematicians who
do this, after that, help them
get an education
in universities and show them that they
can engage in scientific activities,
again inviting them to different
conferences, making guest reports,
creating symposia  seminars and so on
And of course, then
if a girl, a woman, wants to do
scientific
work, there are
entire teams that can help
explain how to apply for work and
postdocs and how to apply for
work at universities, and then when
young specialists begin
work, the
organization can help in
[music]
in conferences organizing conferences
and seminars and making reports and finding
connections
[music]
scientific today it is probably
impossible not to note the revolution in the field of
mathematical methods of machine learning,
which is practically happening before
our eyes and with the advent and successful
use of deep neutron networks,
man has become  in general, rapidly
approaching the creation of artificial
intelligence, so I’m afraid that this was
predicted, but this is a completely new
area of ​​​​activity for mathematics,
processing big
data,
building new network models that
can solve regular problems themselves,
this is very unusual and very
new And therefore a lot  mathematicians
are now interested in this again. It’s difficult for me
to predict How many years and
how this movement in mathematics will
advance, but today I would
say that this is, in a certain sense of
revolution, a
completely separate type of scientific
research that has hitherto not been
applied and unknown, that is, mathematics
is developing in different directions Well,
this is a very new
[music]
direction today, probably in
mathematics most of the cooperation
takes place in English,
but knowledge of the Russian language of course
helps in that it broadens your
horizons in general and you
understand a lot  scientific literature
is written in Russian, this of course
definitely helps. I have
employees in different countries, even I’ll
tell you
in France and Germany, and they very
often say that they use
Russian textbooks because
Russian textbooks are very good,
Russian textbooks are written in
Russian  language and this part of the article is
a lot of articles written in
Russian that are not translated and
which carry very important
information and very interesting scientific
discoveries and a person who knows
Russian has the opportunity to get
additional information and
learn new things that are
unknown  to other scientists This is
mainly in terms of conversation, but of course
most of the communication takes place in
English
[music]
language, we hear people speak Russian, which is what we
needed to
prove. This is, of course, a mathematical
expression with which every
theorem in a mathematical textbook ends, from
the alternating places of the terms, the sum does not
change We  we use this expression very often
we say work schedule
schedule is a mathematical word or
reduce to zero there we use the word
differentiated this is a mathematical
word
we say the limit of patience of many
people the limit of many these are all
mathematical terms that came to
us from
[music]
mathematics I guess I would  said
data analysis or data processing or do you
want one word data this now
seems to me the word
[music] of
the year
[music]
books
Well, probably a master
[music]
Margarita
Kolmogorov
always be a professional in your field,
love what you do and do
what
[  music]
love I really hope that there
will be Progress in terms of
mathematics in Reni
Meno’s proofs of the existence of a solution to the three-dimensional
Nax equation, but I don’t know how much
this will make a big contribution
to the progress of mankind, but
it will certainly make a certain contribution to the progress of mankind
[music]
Di